canettes mouchoirs pièces en métal la
forêt prend parfois des airs de
déchetterie pour les jeunes chasseurs
d'ile-de-france pas question de se
décourager le 24 septembre ils ont
organisé l'opération chassons les
déchets une matinée de nettoyage aux
étangs de la minière à guyancourt
aujourd'hui on est là pour sensibiliser
les jeunes avec les scouts et les jeunes
chasseurs afin de dire voilà faut
travailler dès le départ et avoir une
bonne éducation dès le départ et ne pas
acheter c'est plus agréable de chasse et
de se balader de courir de faire du vélo
dans une forêt propre scouts jeunes
chasseurs sympathisants une cinquantaine
de volontaires ont participé à cette
cinquième édition ils ont été aidés par
une association d'attelage pour
transporter les nombreux déchets moi
j'ai eu la chance de tomber sur beaucoup
de déchet sur pont en bordure de route
que ce soit des bouteilles de bière des
canettes etc et puis on est tombé sur
une carcasse de voiture une vieille ds
qu'on appuie désossée et démonter et
puis on a réussi à la ramener donc non
en termes de quantité je pense qu on
avoisine peut-être les deux tonnes je
pense qu'il ya eu des abus peut-être
dans la chasse d'avant aujourd'hui c'est
plus comme ça il ya une nouvelle chasse
qui se met en place on est à sa tête et
voilà on veut faire changer les choses
que les gens nous connaissent pourquoi
on fait ça et je pense qu'on a notre
place aujourd'hui dans l'environnement
dans l'écologie dans la nature après
l'effort le réconfort
un cocktail a terminé cette matinée tous
les abords des étangs de la minière sont
maintenant propre simplement à espérer
qu'il le reste